it doesn't matter what character I play
you're always your characters lawyer
you're their advocate Dead Poets Society
directed by Peter Weir starring
obviously the great Robin Williams I
remember everything about that movie
Robin was a genius meaning I never met
anybody like him remotely like him he
was a comic genius take 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 they'd all be
different just just endless but funnily
enough he wasn't really the master on
set Peter Weir was a great leader and
showed all of us how to be serious about
making art and that doesn't mean like
self-serious we played around he he had
speakers installed in the classroom so
you could just crank the music I thought
that was work in the hands of a person
who was a serious craftsman it wasn't
some Airy fairy like art thing he was he
he was gonna build a movie brick by
brick Todd Anderson was my character
it's an aspect of me that I've visited
and other characters to somebody who has
no self-confidence and it's funny
because I really I wanted to play meal
there's the character who kill himself
is really outgoing guy and I was pretty
gregarious young man you know so I
thought that I was more right for that
part and Robert Sean Leonard who played
Neal thought he was more right for Todd
because he was very shy and withdrawn
person and Peter had this beautiful
notion Peter Weir that you always cast
for the final color meaning that at the
end of the movie my character needed to
stand up on this desk and say Oh captain
my captain and he wanted to believe that
said that you you have to act the shy
part but so then when the truth comes
out your real self
is revealed
captain my captain sit down mr. Anderson
something I've never forgotten casting
for the final color after Dead Poets
Society I thought I thought that's what
making a movie was like working with
Robin Williams and Peter Weir I had an
amazing experience of these people and
that's what I thought making a movie was
like and I was continually disappointed
after that because it's not what making
movie life often it's business often
people are there for a paycheck when
things go right it all seems very easy
and when things are difficult then it's
like wow you see how hard it is to make
a good movie explorers
directed by Joe Dante my first movie was
River Phoenix I learned a lot watching
rivers career when he did my own Private
Idaho
it was incredibly dangerous thing to do
as a teen idol to play a gay character
it's very common now and it's one of the
biggest things that's shifted from my
generation to my sons as people being
comfortable talking about homosexuality
that was very verboten when River and I
were 21 River was an artist you know he
was he didn't think like that he thought
outside the box like that his whole
family you know were not ordinary
thinkers they were revolutionary
thinkers you know they were they were
the first vegetarians that ever met I
mean we were going to sleep over at his
house and I had these you know mushroom
and avocado burgers and I remember
thinking what is this but they really
opened my eyes and river was a very
beautiful person and obviously you
learned that it's a dangerous road is
the road of a teen celebrity you know or
any kind of celebrity for that matter
Reality Bites starring Winona Ryder
directed by Ben Stiller
so it's Ben Stiller's first movie he was
this immensely talented young man he was
a comic but he's to my money certainly
the comic the way Buster Keaton is a
comic or something I mean he's dark and
serious and wild and mischievous and
strange and talented and of course it
was really Wynonna's movie
Winona made that happen Winona was the
biggest star in the world at that moment
and that whole movie is her passion
project and you know that character was
another aspect of me you know I mean
pretentious and self-serious and full of
himself and wildly insecure and I don't
know it was guys I knew guys I wanted to
be guys I didn't like if you really do
it right doesn't matter who you're
playing you really get immersed in their
point of view I love Troy you know hey
that's my bike is still the best name
for a band
[Music]
the before trilogy before sunset before
sunrise before midnight directed by
Richard Linklater I met Richard
Linklater before Dazed and Confused had
come out but I saw an early screening of
it cuz I was running this theater
company and he came to see the play that
night he told me about before sunrise
you know he sent me the script it's back
you know before email and stuff so we
actually partied all night I remember
saying about him in like four ten the
morning and then I woke up at noon and
there in my my mailbox was a script
that's what I remember it anyway you
know with his handwriting on it hey
check this out it was before sunrise and
I I read it and don't tell him it was a
mess frankly but I knew I wanted to work
with him so I actually thought he was
offering me the part but he wasn't I
realized my agents like no he wants you
to audition so I came in an audition I
auditioned a [ __ ] ton of times and um I
finally got the part and we started
working on the movie some of the best
summers of my life summer in 1994 in
Vienna with Julie Delpy and all I
remember is running lines
we just ran yeah epic lines in that
movie and we just had to spend every day
memorizing writing and people think you
know that the movie has the illusion of
spontaneity its meticulously worst
because if you watch that movie a lot of
the movie plays out in single takes so
it's not a movie
find in the editing room you can't cut
anything out so we could have to
rehearse with us over and over and over
again we rehearse that movie for over a
month before we shot it and that's
that's that's rare with movies nine
years later we did before sunset in nine
years after that we did before midnight
I didn't have an idea that'd be a
trilogy till we finished the third we
spent months and months trying to come
up with a title before sunset um you
know the first film I've been called
before sunrise and anybody said you're
making a sequel what's gonna be called
before sunset and everybody laughs
because it just seems so obvious you
know we were like no no no it should be
called this so we come up with some
potential style or this potential title
and finally one day we were like maybe
we should just call it before sunset
people who are fans of it sometimes ask
me you know will there be a fourth and
there's something that feels complete
about it to me the first one opens with
a couple in their 40s fighting on the
train and the camera pulls back to real
reveal these young people and then in
the third movie we are the couple
fighting in our 40s and and there's
something cyclical about that to revisit
those movies each decade of my life and
getting it to be kind of this shadow
self an alternate universe where Jesse
and Celine really exists you know and
Julie and Rick and I we grew to love
Jesse and Celine still do boyhood
Richard Linklater
I can't separate boyhood from my
relationship with Richard Linklater you
know I mean he had this idea that how
funny most movies about coming-of-age
movies work because they they happen in
one moment whereas literature you can
tell the whole story of somebody's
childhood it's much easier to cover
tunner but because actors age you either
have to hire different actors which kind
of breaks the spell or you have to
pretend like that a person's life was
changed in one moment as opposed to what
boyhood is about is this accumulation of
moments that come to feel like one thing
called your youth it's the one time of
our lives in America anyway we're all in
the same grid first grade through
twelfth grade we all kind of know we're
you know when you're in eighth grade you
know where you're gonna be in three
years you're gonna
in 11th grade it's an interesting
architecture for a movie and I remember
him kind of telling me the idea he
wanted me to do a portrait of fatherhood
you know and to really use myself and my
experiences and as a child of divorce
and I had a marriage that was breaking
up to write about that and help him ride
shotgun with him what he did this huge
huge adventure of trying to make a movie
over 12 years and it's the most
incredible idea I've ever heard I
remember I remember as soon as he said I
was like hold Wow man let's do it
but of course your word who was ever
gonna give you money to make a movie
that is gonna take they're not gonna get
return on for 13 years and you can't
even sign any um contracts cuz you know
it's not legal to sign a contract for
more than seven years so the whole thing
was a handshake deal I didn't think that
we would finish the movie for five or
six years I hoped we did but it wasn't
until we were seven or eight years into
it I was like you know what we're gonna
finish this thing
Gattaca Andrew Nichols first film yeah I
fell in love on that set
you know then we got pregnant and had
Maya that's a great great time of my
life well you know people can say that
but you know all children look a lot
like their parents they act like because
their parents are movie actors she's
somehow different than any other human
being in the plan most people look a lot
like their mom and dad gatok is a
meticulously designed film the costumes
are incredible the art direction is
incredible and it's it's difficult to do
a futuristic movie without a lot of
money we really had to design a world
and Andrew was brilliant you know we got
50s cars and Frank Lloyd Wright
buildings and he just made this whole
hodgepodge of design influences that was
beautiful and and the writing of course
is phenomenal I've done two really good
science fiction
Gattaca and predestination
predestination is a movie that many
people haven't seen but it's one I'm
really proud of the guys who made that
movie the Spirit Brothers are big
Gattaca fans and so I think that's why
they wanted me to be in it as
predestination owes from a design point
of view it owes some ideas to Gattaca
[Music]
predestination in my second film with
the spirit brothers my favorite
predestination story is that the other
day I had a cop pulled me over and I was
like what is it he goes look I'm sorry
to pull you over but I got a no
predestination
I watched it twice what happened yeah in
in music are they and I think they are
and in Wow thank you
I love that movie I love science fiction
that's based on a Robert Heinlein short
story Sara snoot gives one of my
favorite performances I've ever been
party to you know people really talk
about acting you know if you make an
indie movie an art film people talk
about the acting but when the acting
disappears inside a genre film gets lost
because people get the movie works you
get lost in the world you just believe
the character but Sarah snook gets one
just sits she plays a man she plays a
woman she plays in between she was going
like just an amazing performance that
that also serves a science fiction plot
Great Expectations Alfonso Cuaron's
first American movie he's going on to
being one of the great directors of his
generation and I feel proud that I knew
that the second I met him we met at a
diner and Chelsea he wanted me to do
critic stations I had no desire to do
that movie you know that whole novel is
about class and I really felt that if
you're gonna make a movie about class in
America that pits that my character
should be Latino or african-american he
should be you know a person of color but
Alfonso completely disagreed and he
loved before sunrise and he wanted me to
play the part and he was completely
compelling an amazing artist
just the way he talked about movies was
so exciting DeNiro is you know one of a
handful of first-ballot Hall of Famers
that I've ever come in contact with he's
just one of the greatest people of my
profession and he was just he was the
top and then in the last 20 years he's
going on to be one of the greatest
comics of his generation I just did mine
him so much you know and he's a
no-bullshit guy I learned a lot working
with him simply because I was still very
young and I was
for people to give me permission to do
the work I wanted to do going if I were
friends before that started we're kind
of waiting for directors to give us
permission to do great work in De Niro
just comes in and does it you know he's
in charge of his own work I learned a
lot
ultimately like I said they didn't
really how fast I was trying to do
something new with it we all just goofed
around trying to make a story that spoke
to us people liked that movie now and
they liked it when it came out but it
came out a couple weeks after Titanic
and so nobody gave a [ __ ] about anything
but Titanic for about nine months after
Titanic came out particularly another
romance you know that didn't involve a
giant ship sinking and the most
incredible effects of all time and Leo
and Kate and James Cameron so we were
kind of lost in the what he called two
aftershock of Titanic
before the devil knows you're dead
directed by Sidney Lumet Sidney Lumet's
last film he was 83 I know you know I've
worked with a handful of genuine
card-carrying masters from the
filmmaking department but Sidney I mean
I was being directed by a guy who
directed Marlon Brando in one of his
greatest performances in a
black-and-white movie written by
Tennessee Williams and Henry Fonda's
greatest part in 12 Angry Men you know
Al Pacino he directed Al Pacino in
Serpico and Dog Day Afternoon but it
wasn't just like some doddering old dude
you know he was on fire he was not going
to let this opportunity go by he grabbed
it by the hair if you see that movie
it's a young man's movie I mean it's
angry and blistering and surprising and
strange and it's not the work of
somebody phoning anything in I remember
sitting on an airplane with him we were
going to the Toronto Film Festival and
he said to me said you know we told
everybody I was dying and win the Oscar
for this picture that's how dumb the
Oscars are he said everyday just need a
narrative you know and I'm overthinking
there does he mean that he's sick
so you don't let yourself think those
thoughts are you sitting with him you
mean you know you just don't want to
think about if it's his last film it
seems like bad luck or something like
that but not like it was a surprise that
that could have happened
Hamlet directed by Michael Hummer era
written by a young aspiring writer named
William Shakespeare Hamlet lends itself
to reinterpretation more than you know
Dickens I would say and my collaborator
had a brilliant idea this is something
remember when he first talked to me
about he's like he had this vision of of
Hamlet walking through a video store not
being able to decide what movie to rent
and that it's kind of represents an
existential crisis
you know funnily enough they don't even
have video stores anymore but at that
moment in 2000 now it'd be the
equivalent of going online and getting
lost I felt lucky because I was one of
the I'd always had a dream of playing
Hamlet young you're so often on stage
you see older guys you see guys my age
play Hamlet you know really he's knee
drops he's still in school you know he's
supposed to be a student I always
thought and I was proud to be you know
being my 20s and playing Hamlet training
day Jake Coit was a great character but
he existed in relationship to Alonso you
know I mean I got to sit shotgun on on
one of the greatest actors of our time
creating one of his indelible portraits
you know as he worked on that getting to
watch you know we went we didn't ride
around the cops and we saw some crazy
things you know and we Antoine Fuqua is
an amazing director and he was young and
he had something to say
Denzel had something to say and that
script was ice hot but I'd really gotten
a lot of confidence the first 10 years
or so my career outside might have had
some talent but I don't have any
confidence you can't have real
confidence without experience you're
kind of faking it when you start
everybody is you got to and I was just
starting to get confidence enough
confidence to act with Denzel and enough
you know be a shrinking violet you know
anything that I had learned from De Niro
and stuff you know went to another level
with Denzel it because it was it was
just a much more all-encompassing
experience
magnificent seven Antoine said that he
and Denzel were making magnificent seven
and I said that means there's six other
parts dude and I'd better be one of them
and there we were all decided to make a
Hollywood Western Antoine had every toy
we had Gatling guns and one hundred
horses and creams and it's the biggest
budget movie I ever made
it was an event making that movie he's a
hundred and seven in the shade and
raining we'd spend the day on the horse
I being like this wolf suit and just
drew I'd have to change my suit like
four times a day she's dripping in sweat
we had the best stunt team in the world
it's got Jeff - and I was old fashioned
there's nothing like no computer tricks
these guys they were out there it was
like this is like the stuff a legend
these guys I told her that's when I was
like one day we're walking this music
I'm not character this lame death and I
was like I'm the sniper I'd be up there
I should be in the church tower you know
I should get shot up there and fall down
and then then I looked over cuz the lead
Jeff was the least the guy and his son
Nick was my stunt guy and he goes that
means Nick's got a fall from that church
and I was like oh yeah it does Nicoll do
it watching it hell yeah dad and he did
it beautiful beautiful stone Maggie's
plan written and directed by Rebecca
Miller it was wonderful to be directed
by a woman you know 95% of the movies
I've done have been directed by men and
it's just been a I'm a symptom of my era
but Rebecca Miller's just fabulously
dressed funny witty smart and you know
kind of all over the place but then
secretly brilliant Greta Gerwig is you
know I'm working with some of the best
women of my generation you know Julianne
Moore I haven't been in very many
comedies and when I started acting I
really thought that's what I do I
remember when I started my favorite
actor one of them was John Cusack and
Warren Beatty
so Maggie's plan was fun for me to
channel my inner Warren Beatty one of my
favorite lines like you know I don't
want you to fall in the pickle man
something like that I can't remember it
exactly but I like to working with Greta
she comes at acting from a similar
vantage point than I do and Julianne
Moore actually you know we all well
particularly both of them they think
like filmmakers you they they Julie
really understand
the way movies work and what how
storytelling works the the actual
geometry and math of making a good movie
and what an audience wants to see she is
a great awareness of that Greta is a
writer I like being on set acting with
people who write like myself I like
people like me first performed written
and directed by Paul Schrader I had
never worked with Paul before Paul for
people they don't know you know he wrote
taxi driver and when I got this script I
knew it was one of the best characters
that ever been offered he's a great
writer and great writers speak to their
time and speak to their moment and First
Reformed I think speaks to right now in
much the same way when you think about
movies in history movies you know it's
you don't really see very many movies
that deal in a grown-up serious way with
your spiritual life most of us wonder
why we're born and why we die and wonder
what we're doing here
what is it all for why do we go through
all this and there's a certain community
of the world that spends their life
thinking about this which is the
religious community and you don't see
very many of them in movies if you do
it's like in The Exorcist or something
and they're where they're bad guys are
they're comics you don't see a serious
portrait of somebody's dedicated their
life to some of the toughest questions
and Paul is smart enough and
well-educated to write such a party the
movie in a lot of ways is like a scream
it's like a it's a roar from an old lion
you know who's kind of roaring at his
own generation and roaring at young
people he's just asking questions and I
think that that's like one of the jobs
of movies
you